you can't put together an anthology of
writing about Shakespeare in America
without it having a profound effect on
your thinking about Shakespeare I've
been very lucky a kid from Brooklyn who
didn't get Shakespeare in Midwood high
school in Brooklyn and undergraduate at
Columbia who never took a Shakespeare
course but picked up enough Shakespeare
through the core so that when i went to
see shakespeare and get exposed to him
in london in 70s and through the 80s I
was prepared really through the terrific
education I had to grapple with what
these plays and brilliant productions
were about when de Tocqueville came to
America and others one of the first
things they realized was along with the
Bible every everyone had a copy of
Shakespeare and there are a couple of
reasons for that one was in an
educational curriculum in which oratory
and public speaking was important
Shakespeare was great those speeches and
Julius Caesar and other plays with
Macbeth as well or wonderful another
reason is in the 19th century
Shakespeare was simply popular across
the classes from the highest to the
lowest Shakespeare was really part of
the fabric of American culture and in
the period say 15 years on either side
of the Civil War it truly was a culture
saturated in Shakespeare there are a
number of works that I've anthologized
in this collection that have utterly
changed the way I think about
Shakespeare Jane Addams sa a modern Lear
is brilliant it's it's a hundred years
ahead of its time in trying to
understand the personal factors the
social and political factors that
connect with a play written now over 400
years ago so whether I'm teaching King
Lear in a survey course or I'm working
with as I have been directors of King
Lear that's going right into those
classrooms and that theater experience
one of the things you discover in
writing about Shakespeare in America is
that it's a lot more complicated and
there are things that are
rest to be honest there are things that
we cannot say to each other as Americans
or when we think one thing we're saying
another who was saying something
publicly with thinking of another
privately you get presidents in the 19th
century who was strongly anti-slavery
like President Adams who could then
write an essay saying how disturbed if
not frantically discussed that he was
that Desdemona would have sex with a
black man of fellow how do you account
for this split what I'm suggesting is
reading what smart leading people and
some of the best thinkers and minds in
our country have written about
Shakespeare tell you something about
what's left unspoken what doesn't make
it into the history books the fractures
that still divide us the issues that
were still wrestling to resolve and
looking at a through Shakespeare
provides an access that formal documents
and traditional narrative American
history don't permit when Hamlet was
first performed in 1600 or so no one had
seen Hamlet and one of the exciting
things about the performance of Hamlet
by G is for GIS in the Pacific Theater
was many of his men had never seen
Shakespeare before so it's not important
to me that people come to Shakespeare's
work having studied the work having been
taught it in junior high or high school
what matters is that impact that
collision at that production in Hawaii
for these men who would fought at some
of the bloodiest battles in the Second
World War Hamlet at one point says
conscience does make cowards of us all
and one of the GIS and the audience
shouted back you got that right buddy
that is what I live for both in terms of
what I research or recently working with
public theater production that took much
ado to Rikers Island watching that kind
of immediate connection between inmates
many of whom had never seen Shakespeare
before who were connected to those works
in ways that you can't recreate in a
classroom or capture
in a classroom so I'm not really worried
about how much people study Shakespeare
I'm just interested in everyone having
that shot whether its soldiers 1944-45
or prisoners in Rikers Island